[Música]
menos de una semana después de aprobada
una tercera dosis de la vacuna pfizer
para mayores de 60 años más de 100.000
israelíes la han recibido ya el objetivo
del gobierno del Primer Ministro naftalí
benet es terminar de vacunar a esta
población para finales del mes de agosto
se decidió hacerlo y llevar a cabo esta
tercera dosis antes que otros países
porque los estudios que han estado
manejando los expertos sanitarios que
han asesorado al gobierno indicaban que
la vacuna de pfizer perdía efecto perdía
efecto mucho efecto al cabo de los cinco
o seis meses parece que quien se vacunó
en enero tiene un 16% de protección y
quién se vacuno en abril tiene un 75% de
protección muchos expertos a decir
verdad dudan de la veracidad de estos
estudios y sin embargo el consenso
general es que una tercera dosis tal vez
no ayude a que se siga propagando el
coronavirus pero no hará daño
[Música]
septiembre arrancará aquí en el Reino
Unido el programa Buster o el refuerzo
con una tercera vacuna para al menos 32
millones de personas a partir de los 50
años o quienes tengan enfermedades
graves o antecedentes médicos
importantes el propósito de este
programa de vacunación es extender y
aumentar la inmunidad de quienes ya
tuvieron la primera y la segunda dosis
de la vacuna contra el 19 especialmente
de cara al otoño y el invierno cuando
aumentan y aparecen de manera natural
gripas y otro tipo de enfermedades
respiratorias el propósito del gobierno
es vacunar al menos dos millones y medio
de personas cada semana para alcanzar a
cumplir esta meta de 32 millones de
personas completamente vacunados o con
esta tercera dosis para antes de la
temporada de navidad
tras el ingreso de la variante Delta a
el país y con la intención de reabrir la
fronteras a turistas en los próximos
meses Uruguay facilitará una tercer
dosis de vacuna contra el coronavirus
aquellas personas que ya hayan recibido
dos dosis de laboratorio sinovac podrán
ahora recibir una tercera de laboratorio
pfizer las personas inmunos deprimidas
tendrán prioridad ante la solicitud de
la Organización Mundial de la Salud de
retrasar este tipo de planes de
vacunación el ministro de salud pública
de Uruguay Indicó que se continuará con
lo programado Y a partir del 16 de
agosto se estarán aplicando esta tercer
dosis actualmente Uruguay cuenta con un
64% de la población ya vacunada con dos
dosis y se espera que alcance un 74%
[Música]